[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show and
what a bonus show it is i have sort of a
quirky little story relating to voter
fraud and i'll tell you the story but i
also want to tell you about how some of
the headlines that have been circulating
about the story have been totally
deceptive clickbait so the the story is
that a man who worked on Donald Donald
Trump's campaign in Michigan has been
found guilty on 10 counts of election
fraud his name's brandon hall political
activist and it turns out that he forged
signatures on petition forms in 2012 and
he now faces up to five years in prison
he's 27 years old and he and his friend
zack savage which apparently is his real
name forged signatures in support of
judicial candidate chris buidling i
believe is the right name and savage
received immunity from charges from the
attorney general's office in it in
exchange for testifying against his
buddy the High Court overturned the
Michigan Court of Appeals Paul was
charged with a felony he argued in his
defense that these should be misdemeanor
charges because of a statement printed
on the petitions but ultimately it did
not go well so yet that this is again
it's a story of someone who in 2016
supported Trump committing voter fraud
totally unrelated to Donald Trump four
years ago now when you look at the
headlines because Michigan has been in
the news there have been some really
deceptive headlines written which say
something like you know it basically the
headlines imply that weight voter fraud
in Michigan the real voter fraud is a
trump supporter in Michigan as if it has
anything to do with the Michigan recount
request and blah blah blah blah this is
a guy who's voter fraud was four years
ago and it had nothing whatsoever to do
with Donald Trump nor the 2016 results
in Michigan so yeah it's interesting
because it continues to be Republicans
that get caught for different types of
voter fraud and election fraud but this
is nothing to
do with 2016 Michigan yeah I'm sure the
clickbait titles is is part of the
reason why the story's blowing up to the
point where it is that now yeah but this
also goes to show I mean why voter fraud
is so rare because the penalties are so
strict five years in prison for
something like this is very harsh no
doubt about it and and there's this
assumption from some who are just
uninformed that it's super easy to
commit a lack of voter fraud and vote
multiple times or make up a name or all
these different things number one it's
very rare number 2 the penalties are
strict there was that woman we covered
what stay i think it was also michigan
although i'm not told maybe was yeah i
think is iowa actually was it indiana
illinois in any case there was a woman
who in order to show how easy it is to
vote multiple times tried to vote twice
during early voting in uh in october i
believe and she was caught and faces uh
prison prison time uh so yeah it's it's
just not that easy yeah it was iowa and
that was though so ironic at the time
good yep trump on and on would say that
the only reason he would be able to lose
that the election was rigged but of
course at that point no one thought he
was going to win yeah and uh yeah turns
out voter fraud can happen on both sides
it absolutely can and uh in this case it
did but it has nothing whatsoever to do
with the Trump election in 2016 there is
very strange news out of Ohio where sex
with animals has gone one step closer to
legal after the state Senate voted 31 to
0 to strengthen Ohio law and I'm sorry
illegal did I say legal I meant illegal
it is one step closer to being illegal
to have sex with animals in Ohio the
bill now goes to the house it would
number one prohibit a person from
engaging in sexual conduct with an
animal and related acts provide for the
seizure and impoundment of animals that
are the subject of violations which is
weird sounds like you're basically
punishing the animal but I guess maybe
you're not by taking it away from the
perpetrator and it would also authorize
a sentencing court to require an
offender to undergo psychological
evaluation or counseling and why is this
interesting it's interesting because
there aren't that many states left which
don't have actual laws outlaw outlawing
bc AO
or as I used to say bestiality I don't
know that actually said that but people
would write in and they'd say David what
is bestiality its bestiality in any case
I now make it very clear that I say
bestiality uh yeah there was a period
you might remember Pat before the
Supreme Court decision on same-sex
marriage where you could actually find
more states where it was legal to have
sex with animals then states in which
two men could get married and it sort of
was one of the ways in which it which
the the absurdity of same-sex marriage
law the United States was exposed I
support this Ohio law making it illegal
to have sex with animals yeah I'd have
to agree that that also kinda goes the
slippery slope argument to where people
would say that if we allow gay people
get married yeah and people want to
start marrying their dogs and their pigs
and everything else yeah and uh yeah I
mean I'm totally as a as a advocate for
you animal right yeah totally in favor
of Ohio moving in this direction if we
think of Venn diagrams I think that the
Venn diagram of vegans overlapping with
people who have sex with animals is
probably quite small i would think i
think most people would be against
bestiality just because it's it just
seems disgusting to them and just kind
of perturbs them but you know if you
look at it from a from a rights
perspective there is a whole other angle
their tab so we can't give consent now
the only other side to this would be if
you believe that uh paedophilia and
zoofilia right attraction to animals are
not sort of logical decisions that
people make but rather something in the
brain or a disorder of some kind then
you might have someone who has made the
dietary decision to be vegan but can't
help being attracted to animals I mean
it depends on what your view of what
zoofilia is is in a way yeah and I mean
I'm not uh against any sort of thought
crimes I think you should be on without
well within your rights to have those
sort of uh feely as I guess yeah you
know likening to those things
attractions those things if you don't
act on them then that's a whole nother
story yep and that actually I mean not
that we want to get into a whole
discussion about pedophilia but that's
one of the big discussions around
pedophilia and there are those who say
uh people people that say they are
pedophiles
but that they are able to recognize that
those instincts are wrong and never act
on them as far as they say and they and
they argue you know I this is totally
under control I mean I i I'd recognize
that I have an attraction to kids uh but
I know it's wrong I've never acted on it
I would never act on it and that's where
you get some disagreement about if
someone's expressing that that already
is a danger to children but there's no
actionable crime of course that you
could you could ever prosecute but it is
something people talk about is there
such a thing as someone who's just a a
non-active pedophile and I think of
course it exists there's no doubt about
it yeah I don't think you can blame
someone to for having that attraction if
it's just something that subconscious
going on in their brains turn of course
and and this is something that's that so
many people see as disgusting that I
think a lot of people would just hide
that so the fact that people are able to
come out and open their voice about it
uh very interesting it's an interesting
conversation nonetheless although I've
not it's not an area of expertise of
mine that I really looked into too much
and taken a position on uh just as a as
a note in urban areas dogs are the most
typically sexually abused animals in
more rural locations and I don't think
this is a surprise to anybody in the
audience it's horses sheep and donkeys
although I've heard of the occasional uh
uh uh goat right but you know that no
it's not that's the stuff of urban look
a subtle I guess not urban of rural lore
uh in some way shape or form okay so a
bestiality legal in the US in uh okay
look at my states here in Washington DC
just not that many animals there yeah uh
hawaii Kentucky Nevada New Hampshire New
Jersey New Mexico Ohio Texas Vermont
West Virginia and Wyoming now there are
still often animal cruelty laws in those
states which you can prosecute
bestiality as a general active animal
cruelty but there are not specific
statutes that talk about sexual contact
with animals that's the thing I wonder
if there's a law actually permitting
bestiality or they just never got around
to passing it it's I think in most cases
it probably all I don't think that
there's too many laws on the books that
say have sex with animals go go right
ahead i think that it's not specifically
forbidden and maybe not included
under some of these animal cruelty laws
they should follow hyo's lead and get
around to that I guess they should
absolutely should I applaud oh it's good
to have something to applaud a
republican-led uh state for right that
that they're doing something right I I
think that's a really good thing but a
story about the new york times we sort
we use the new york times as a source
for many stories on the show but i don't
talk about the new york times nearly as
often and there is a report out that
says that subscriptions to the new york
times they're paid online subscriptions
have grown ten times faster than normal
since the election of president elect
Donald Trump they say they've seen an
increase of approximately a hundred and
thirty-two thousand paid subscriptions
to the news products this is interesting
because we've seen a significant
increase as well in the number of new
members I believe that we closed out
November I think with 230 something new
members which is more than double the
previous new member record that we've
ever had i think the prior record was
something like a hundred and fifteen a
hundred and twenty or something like
that and by like the tenth or by the
12th or 13th of the month we had already
reached the prior single month record of
the low hundreds like i mentioned and i
think it's very clear what's going on
it's not yeah we were wondering is it
just doesn't I've been talking to other
liberal shows what are you seeing what's
going on there clearly has been an
awakening to the problems with the media
coverage we saw prior to november eighth
the counter though is is the new york
times corporate media uh i mean it's
it's certainly a massive corporation but
they did endorse Hillary Clinton and
they did pretty but significant
critiques of Donald Trump so clearly the
New York Times still perceived at least
by these hundred and thirty two thousand
people that have signed up as the type
of counterbalancing force that we need
for upcoming elections we know that
corporate media can also have an
inherent bias to it you don't have to
look much further than like MSNBC or fox
news yeah I'm you know New York Times
reputable organization the paper record
and that now that they're getting more
subscriptions I guess Donald Trump can't
call them the failing New York Times
anymore that's I I didn't think about
that yet Trump has made a big deal out
of
talking about houses it's so horrible
the New York Times is falling apart in
etcetera etcetera but tenfold increase
after the Trump win we had a November
that was double the prior record of new
subscribers which is great and of course
thank you this is the bonus show to
everybody who's listening to the show or
watching the bonus show we've got really
big things coming up we've got the
fundraiser starting next month and this
is all going to be possible if and only
if we continue to see growth and viewer
support so thanks to everybody that's it
for today and we will talk to you
tomorrow on the friday show the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]